Bonjour! Aujourd'hui on va
parler d'une femme autrice,
proto-féministe, bien badass du début du
XVIIe siècle, mais comme c'était une femme
elle n'est pas restée dans les mémoires malgré ses
efforts pour changer tout ça. Quelle indignité.
Aemilia Bassano est née le 27 janvier 1569 à
Londres. Ses parents sont Baptiste Bassano,
musicien de cour de la reine Elisabeth et
originaire de Venise, et Margret Johnson.
Peut-être que sa famille était juive, ou avait des
origines juives, mais les sources sont incertaines
à ce sujet. En tout cas, elle est baptisée.
La vie d'Emilia est bien connue grâce à ses
lettres, sa poésie, ses dossiers judiciaires
et le journal de l'astrologue Simon Forman
qui raconte leurs interactions. Consulter
un astrologue était courant à cette époque.
Emilia a une sœur, et deux frères qui
n'atteignent pas l'âge adulte. Leur père
meurt lorsqu'elle n'a que sept ans et lui laisse
une dot de 100 livres qu'elle pourra toucher à
son mariage ou à ses 21 ans. Après sa mort,
Emilia est envoyée vivre chez Susan Bertie,
comtesse de Kent. On ignore si elle était
au service de la comtesse ou sa pupille,
mais cette dernière considère qu'il est important
que les jeunes filles reçoivent le même niveau
d'éducation que les jeunes hommes. Elle reçoit
donc une éducation humaniste et apprend le latin.
Elle vit ensuite chez Margaret Clifford, comtesse
de Cumberland, et sa fille lady Anne Clifford,
en tant que sa tutrice et compagne. Elle y
bénéficie d'une bibliothèque importante et
désigne Margaret Clifford, dans ses écrits,
comme son inspiration et mécène principale.
Sa mère meurt lorsque Emilia n'a que 18 ans. Peu
de temps après, elle fait la connaissance de lord
Henry Carey, cousin de la reine et mécène des arts
et du théâtre. Carey a quarante-cinq ans de plus
qu'Emilia mais devient son amant. Il lui verse
une pension de 40 livres par an jusqu'à ce qu'elle
tombe enceinte de lui en 1592, à vingt-trois
ans. Pour conserver les apparences Carey lui
offre alors une grosse somme d'argent et la
marie à Alfonso Lanier, musicien de la reine qui
se trouve aussi être le cousin germain d'Emilia.
Son mariage avec Alfonso n'est pas heureux. Elle
s'inquiète du manque d'avancement de son mari
et regrette sa liaison avec Henry, désormais
décédé, ainsi que le temps passé à la cour.
Le journal de Forman, son astrologue, raconte.
Elle a un fils, Henry, issu de sa
liaison, et une fille, Odillya,
qui meurt à dix mois. Le journal de Forman suggère
aussi qu'elle fait plusieurs fausses couches.
Après la mort d'Alfonso en 1613,
Emilia doit gagner sa vie et ouvre
une école mais est arrêtée à deux
reprises à cause de différends sur
le prix de la location des locaux. Son
école perd en popularité suite à cela.
On connaît peu le reste de sa vie. Elle engage
des poursuites à l'encontre du frère de son mari,
qui doit lui payer 20 livres. On ignore si
la somme a bien été versée. Elle passe ses
dernières années avec la famille de son
fils, et meurt le 3 avril 1645, à 76 ans.
Si j'ai choisi de vous parler d'Emilia Bassano, ce
n'est pas pour ses talents relatifs de directrice
d'école mais pour ses écrits. En 1611 elle publie
un recueil de poésie, Salve Deus Rex Judaeorum.
Elle a alors 45 ans et il est à cette époque
extrêmement rare et nouveau qu'une femme anglaise
publie ses écrits. Seule la religion est un
thème jugé convenable pour les femmes, elles
peuvent traduire des textes ou écrire sur leur
expérience religieuse, mais guère plus et avec
l'accord de leur mari bien sûr. Elle n'est que la
quatrième femme anglaise à publier de la poésie
et la première à tenter d'en vivre, la diffusion
de son recueil pouvant lui permettre de trouver
des mécènes. Chaque poème est dédié à une femme
différente, de la reine consort aux femmes qu'elle
a connues comme Margaret Clifford. Il était
courant, pour les auteurs peu fortunés ou peu
connus, d'attirer l'attention de mécènes de cette
manière, en leur dédiant tel ou tel poème voire
même en vantant leurs vertus dans leurs textes.
Cependant ce regroupement de femmes est inhabituel
voire unique pour l'époque, jamais auparavant
un livre n'avait été dédié qu'à des femmes.
Dans ses écrits elle s'inspire
d'auteurs anciens et de livres
de Veronica Franco et Christine de
Pizan, dont j'ai déjà parlé dans une
vidéo. On trouve aussi des références théâtrales,
notamment à Shakespeare. Son poème-titre raconte
l'histoire de la passion du Christ de façon
satirique, et presque entièrement du point
de vue des femmes qui l'entourent ce qui est
inédit pour l'époque. Dans d'autres textes elle
s'attaque à la vanité des hommes et justifie
la liberté dont les femmes devraient pouvoir
jouir. Elle s'attarde sur Caludia Procula, la
femme de Pilate qui tente d'intervenir lors de
la crucifixion de Jésus. Elle défend aussi les
femmes qui suivent Jésus jusqu'à sa crucifixion,
et s'attaque au péché originel, défendant Eve et
considérant qu'Adam est aussi coupable qu'elle.
Son dernier poème est dédié à Margaret Clifford
et sa fille et décrit leur maison de campagne.
Le règne du roi James, sous lequel Emilia
écrit, n'était pas très sympathique envers
les femmes. Surtout celles qui tentaient de
prendre la parole publiquement. La religion
était un thème d'écriture jugé convenable,
à l'époque, mais l'aspect parodique voire
grotesque qu'en donne Emilia sont considérés
par certains comme radicaux voire hérétiques.
D'autres considèrent Emilia comme profondément
religieuse. Ses textes sont vus, de nos jour,
comme une première forme de féminisme. Elle y met
en avant les femmes, considérant qu'elles doivent
s'investir dans le monde matériel et s'élever
au même niveau que les hommes. Elle est aussi
la première à proposer une contre-mémoire de la
mémoire dominante, vue cette fois sous le prisme
des femmes qui y contribuent. Un peu comme ce
que j'essaie de faire ici. Ce qui est ironique,
c'est que Emilia a ensuite elle-même
été oubliée pendant plusieurs siècles.
On connaît peu la réception globale de ses
écrits, mais bien qu'ils soient de qualité
ils ne la rendent pas riche. Les procès
qu'elle entreprend par la suite témoignent
de son besoin d'argent, il est probable
qu'elle n'ait pas trouvé de mécène suite
à sa publication et elle ne tente plus
jamais de publier ses écrits. Il existe
de nos jours neuf copies de son Salve
Deus, donc cinq complètes ou presque.
Emilia vivait donc à la même époque que William
Shakespeare, et écrivait. Il est donc tout naturel
que les théories les plus folles
circulent à son sujet. La paternité
de William Shakespeare sur ses œuvres
est contestée depuis le XIXe siècle,
et l'une des théories veut
qu'Emilia soit l'autrice des pièces.
Parmi les arguments avancés on trouve l'emploi
des noms: Bassanio dans Le Marchand de Venise,
Emilia dans Othello, qui est le premier
personnage féminin à tenir des propos
féministes dans le théâtre anglais. Dans Titus
Andronicus, on trouve ensemble les personnages
d'Aemilius et Bassianus. En tout on retrouve
six Emilia ou des variations de ce prénom dans
les pièces de Shakespeare, bien qu'il soit peu
courant pour l'époque, et deux Bassano. Le nom
d'Otello serait inspiré du jésuite Girolamo
Otello, originaire de la ville de... Bassano.
Des références à l'italien et à
l'hébreu, dans les pièces de Shakespeare,
sont également pointées du doigt car il
ne semble pas qu'il parlait ces langues.
De plus Emilia jouait du luth, de la harpe
et du virginal et s'y connaissait en musique,
étant fille et femme de musicien. Or on
retrouve énormément de termes musicaux
dans les textes de Shakespeare, bien qu'il
n'ait pas de formation musicale avérée.
Enfin Emilia est la maîtresse de Henry
Carey, qui durant les deux dernières
années de leur relation dirige la compagnie
de théâtre qui joue les pièces de Shakespeare.
Emilia n'est cependant qu'une des
douze prétendants à la paternité
des pièces de Shakespeare, sans compter
Shakespeare lui-même, quand même. N'étant
pas très portée sur les complots, je ne
m'attarderai pas plus sur cette théorie.
Une autre idée voudrait que Emilia ait
été une collaboratrice de Shakespeare,
ou qu'elle soit sa fameuse Dark Lady. La Dark
Lady de Shakespeare est une femme qui apparaît
dans ses Sonnets, maîtresse ou femme aimée qui
l'aurait éconduit. Elle est décrite comme une
femme sombre de cheveux et de peau. Emilia est
décrite comme «black» dans l'une des seules
descriptions d'elle faite par un cousin, ce qui
signifie pour l'époque qu'elle avait les cheveux
noirs ou bruns ou un air méditerranéen.
Logique, vu ses origines italiennes.
Il est donc possible que les nombreux indices
qui font penser à certains qu'Emilia a écrit
les pièces de Shakespeare soient en fait
des dédicaces de l'auteur à cette femme
qu'il connaissait. Qui sait? Cette thèse est
également controversée car on manque de preuves
sur l'identité de cette Dark Lady. On ignore si
elle était d'origine méditerranéenne ou africaine.
Il existe au moins cinq autre candidates
potentielles à ce titre, et elle pourrait même
tout à fait être une invention de Shakespeare.
Moi, je sais que c'est Martha Jones, mais chut.
Quoi qu'il en soit, la juxtaposition des carrières
d'Emilia Lanier et de Shakespeare met en évidence
le contexte socio-économique et culturel de
l'époque, qui créait de nettes différences
entre les carrières des poètes et des poétesses.
Des différences qu'on retrouve dans sa mémoire
aussi: comme le disent Marianne Hirsch
et Valerie Smith, «ce dont une culture se
souvient et ce qu'elle choisit d'oublier
sont intimement liés aux questions de
pouvoir et d'hégémonie, et donc au genre».
La mémoire d'Emilia Lanier s'est perdue au
fil des siècles, et elle n'est réétudiée
que depuis ces dernières décennies; grâce
aux mouvements de gender studies et aussi grâce
aux théories farfelues la reliant à Shakespeare.